let's go straight to the phone jessica
how are you
hi john i'm good how are you outstanding
good morning how can i help
good morning um so i've been dealing
with
some issues in my marriage regarding
infidelity
um i've been married for 10 years and we
have
two kids and i just don't i saw your
post the other day about
mercy and forgiveness and i was just
you know wanting to get some guidance on
like
when to keep giving mercy and
forgiveness or when
you know is it enough so tell me about
your the history of your marriage ten
years
tell me about it yeah so i mean um
everything you know we've
everything was pretty much okay and i
was like you know happy we just had a
child last year and
our second baby and i thought my family
was complete and everything but
um i went out of town with the kids and
came back and found out that he had been
um you know going out and partying and
seeing other women
and i'm just you know struggling with
this a lot so is this
is this recent has been going on for the
arc of the decade you all have been
together
so that you know i just found that out
recently but um when he came clean about
everything he he did say that
he had been with at least you know three
women
during the 10 years of marriage
[Music]
and um so we were working things out i
forgave him and i
was trying to work things out with him
but um a couple months ago i just
found some emails where he had gone to
meet up with a prostitute
so i was kind of just shaken by that and
i'm not sure if i'm able to
continue with him or not so what do you
want to do
i feel like i'm ready to move on
and when you say ready i feel like i'm
ready to move on that sends
pretty benign finding out that somebody
after a decade has been cheating on you
hiring prostitutes um yeah tell me how
you feel
i feel well at first i was really ready
to forgive you know i thought it was
just like
you know we've been together for a long
time we got married young
um but he kind of i don't know i guess
his attitude about it like
the days where i didn't feel good i felt
like he didn't give me like
you know a shoulder to cry on or like
listen or with compassion you know well
a compassionate person isn't gonna
have serial affairs and call prostitutes
right so
somebody who cares about your feelings
isn't gonna do that um
so i wouldn't expect that in your moment
of need and crisis that
suddenly this person is going to show up
and be the knight in shining armor that
you thought he was for the last decade
um how old are your kids
well the youngest one is only one year
old and the other one's a first grader
yeah so you're in it up to your eyeballs
already right
yeah i mean like i said everything
seemed okay i thought you know our
family was complete
you know it just kind of came as a shock
to me that it came at this time in my
life whenever everything was good like
had it been at a time when we weren't so
good like i could understand but
so what what what can i help you with
well i guess i mean he's you know of
course asking for forgiveness and
you know i just
don't know if i should keep giving
forgiveness at this point
so forgiveness and tolerating
unhealthy unsafe behavior are two
totally different things
and so i'm a huge proponent of
forgiveness i'm a
forgiveness is baggage that we carry
around other people hurt us
right um it's like punching yourself in
the nose
and hoping somebody else will bleed um
when you don't forgive somebody it's
just it's just a waste of your own
energy but that doesn't mean that
you allow yourself to repeatedly get bit
by the same rattlesnake
right that you keep sticking your hand
back in the bag hoping the snake won't
bite you again
it's gonna bite you it's shown it's
gonna bite you and
it's told you i'm gonna bite you it's
demonstrated over and over this is what
i do
and so i'll forgive the snake the snake
is what it is i'm gonna stop but i'm not
putting my hand in the bag
and i'm going to tie the bag off i'm
going to give it to somebody else
because i'm going to quit carrying that
bag around
and so forgiveness mercy those are
different than continually letting
yourself get kicked
right and here's the other thing
one of the most damaging moments of this
besides the betrayal coming from
your husband right that sense of just
utter what do i do now i've got this
perfect little family and all of a
sudden it is not what i thought
is this frightening scary moment
where you jessica no longer trust
jessica
because jessica thought everything was
good and jessica thought i had a
great little family with its own little
ups and downs but the things were great
and you've lost trust in yourself and
these are really critical moments when
you've got to have people around you
that can help you see clearly
and help you plot out what the next
point's going to be because it's not as
simple as just saying you know what i'm
through
i'm moving out tomorrow if you don't
have a place to move if you have a
if you're a stay-at-home mom and you've
got a kid that you're homeschooling in
first grade and
or half quarantined schooling or
whatever and you've got a one-year-old
still toddling around the house
it's not so easy so you're gonna have to
get some folks to walk alongside you
are you convinced that the marriage is
over
i mean i i see like
you know the man that he is that you
know takes care of his responsibilities
and his family and loves us and cares
about us
hold on hold on he is that's not a man
who's going to be hiring prostitutes and
his wife is not taking care of his
responsibilities
he says that he considers it progress
that he didn't actually
he says he got there and he was there
but then he felt bad and left and didn't
do anything
but i mean obviously i don't have any
proof that he didn't do anything
nonsense
nonsense he says that that's progress
that he's trying to get better
nope i'm gonna 100 disagree with that
and you can give him the number to the
show and tell him to call me um
no absolutely zero percent progress
to call a prostitute and just go hang
out in a hotel and just be like hey
what's up
i'm just this is part of my halfway
house i just call prostitutes pay them
for their time
and we play cards and then i go home
that's not progress
progress would be coming to you on hands
and knees saying i have failed you
i've failed our kids i've failed our
marriage
i've broken the vowels that i swore betw
before
our friends and our family and our
community and if
if we're people of faith be behind or in
front of whatever deity we we pledged
ourselves against
and this will never happen again and
here's my credit cards so i'm not going
to be stupid
um here's the number to a marriage
therapist here's the number to our
financial advisor
here's all the credit card statements
that's what
like submission looks like that's what
humility that's what i screwed up real
real
bad and i'm gonna do everything i can to
make it right that's progress
nonsense progress i'm uh only i didn't
inhale
you know the cheese louise you're gonna
get me all fired up and it's the morning
here
jessica so here's the deal um not
progress
i'm never going to be in a position
where i'm going to tell somebody this
marriage is over
if somebody's not safe that's going to
be a call that you're going to have to
make
i will tell you that somebody who
is does not come back from doing
something stupid from having
an affair and is not utterly repentant
on their hands and face
ready to um partner with you and a
professional therapist or a pastor
a couple of of married couples in your
lives that you know well
that you trust um and is not
ready to turn over everything and be
totally clear and transparent
i'm not buying it i'm not buying it
somebody's good that's not going to let
you have
really hard days and pick up the slack
with the kids
that's not going to give you a shoulder
to cry on is it going to let you
leave the house for some time because
you're going to have to reorient
yourself to a new marriage
to a new partner to a new you because
you don't trust yourself anymore
um man that's just the wrong attitude
all the way across the board
and somebody who's been a serial cheater
over the course of a decade who's seeing
prostitutes you see in prostitutes in
the middle of covet for god's sake
we're not supposed to even go outside
right we like meeting a prostitute in a
hotel with a mask on god almighty dude
yeah i'm not buying it um i'm not going
to be the one that tells you to pull the
trigger that's going to be decision you
make
i'm going to tell you that i'm not
seeing any sort of repentant behavior
any sort of you know what i was wrong
let's make this
different let's change it sounds like he
doesn't think you're going to do
anything
and i want to also publicly acknowledge
women in these in these awful situations
because there's economic ramifications
to just walking out the door right
um it sounds all cool to say i'm
marching right
but you have a one-year-old and a first
grader and you've got to think about
rent and you've got to think about food
and you have to think about child care
and
all of those things take wisdom all
those things take careful careful
planning
and so please get with somebody today
get with somebody that you trust
that you can be vulnerable with have
them go to an attorney with you if that
ends up being your next step
have them sit down with your husband um
if you
decide you want to have further
conversations but
i'm progress nonsense man nonsense
1-844-693 dude you call me progress
god almighty